search and rescue ship the Aquarius
which has saved thousands of migrants
from the Mediterranean has announced its
ceasing operations Doctors Without
Borders merger which runs the mission
blamed pressure from European countries
initiated by Italy the charity said Rome
had sabotaged his efforts to save lives
for the last two months the ship has
been confined to the port in Marseille
following allegations it broke the law
the Italian government accused those
behind the mission of running a taxi
service to Italian ports by carrying
people on the ship according to
International Organization for Migration
more than 2,000 people have died or gone
missing this year in attempt to reach
Europe via the Mediterranean well live
now to dr. tom and de Kock who is going
to discuss this further project
coordinator for the Aquarius thanks for
coming out of the program tom why
exactly have you decided to give up on
this well we certainly haven't given up
we've been forced to stop operations can
you explain why in the last three months
we've had our flag stripped twice once
expressly from Italian pressure to the
Panamanian maritime Authority most
recently we've had a trumped-up waste
profiteering legal process started in
Catania Sicily and it's part of a longer
two-year smear campaign not just of
ourselves but of the whole
search-and-rescue community if you'd
like to refer to it as such all of it
attempting to switch the focus on to us
away from the vulnerable who are at
present drowning at sea
Tommy if you throw in the towel now
won't thousands more migrants now be at
risk we're doing this precisely because
we want to be where they are and be in
the position to save them sometimes you
have to switch tacks to get back into
the position to help people and that's
consequently what we've been forced to
do if we look at what Italy's accused
Aquarius of doing is said that they're
providing a taxi service to its ports
can you understand the concerns that
they've raised what are your views on
that it's a I mean it's an easy claim to
say that we are a taxi service it's a
way of creating hyperbole it's a way of
making an easy summary of a very complex
situation but we're not a taxi service
we are association of DA during
Siddhartha's working with mariners in
the sea to save people's lives it's not
a taxi service it's making such a claim
it's patently absurd yeah I mean and
they've said they've said that you've
helped save migrants making dangerous
crossing to Europe from Libya and
elsewhere but you face this strong
opposition particularly from Italy and
they've their policies that migrants
picked up at sea should be returned to
Libya by the country's Coast Guard but
you've kind of helped them get to the
Italian ports haven't you in the past
prior to the closure of ports we brought
them to the closest port of safety which
is a legal concept to which Italy is a
party to how Europe chooses to make
assessments for asylum claims is it a
European issue but ultimately saying
that Libyan Coast Guard is responsible
for bringing them back
to libya has been acknowledged by the
UNHCR three times 2012 2014 and again
this September as an active luminol
which means putting people who have a
human right to flee and a right not to
be sent back into grave danger where
indefinite and arbitrary detention is a
common practice is not an acceptable
alternative and that's not acceptable
for us if we look at you know from the
Italian perspective they're trying to
control illegal migration to Europe
that's that's the perspective they're
putting so how are they going to avoid
returning these migrants back to Libya
and the other countries that they're
traveling from you mean how are they
going to try and avoid it I mean the
European the European Union has
something called chaos which is a
comprehensive European Asylum system at
present there is something called the
Dublin regulation it dictates that every
border nation is responsible for
everybody who arrives there the preamble
to creating that was the border states
take their migration very seriously
consequently it is left room for
populist and right-wing politicians to
create and stoke fear and use what is
arguably not a migration crisis the
European Commission has admitted it's as
much to create fear
[Music]
one hundred thousand people crossing the
Mediterranean is a drop is a very very
small drop in the bucket of a population
the ultimate point here is that will
that what what Italian and other
European politicians are seeking is
creating this into a discussion about
migration and it is most certainly not a
discussion about migration is a
discussion about rescue at sea okay dr.
tom de Kock project coordinator for the
Aquarius thank you very much for coming
on to the program to explain the
situation thank you
you